my husband was killed in a far away
land this place is so bar and I can't
understand what he would have seen out
here there she is far away
down welcome to Australia this should be
interesting it's all very Outback
Adventure isn't it I'm not saying it's
for
[Music]
everyone
who are you I Nilla he all Aline I'm not
good with
children when you first come to this
land you look but you not see now you
get her eyes open for the first
time I am going to bring Far Away Downs
back to
life Nala will you help me
yes Sergeant Callahan and the police
there's a halfblood Aboriginal child out
here somewhere run I thought we might
put him in the good hands of the
church get off my
property to save this house I need money
out of here your cattle's worth more
than you
land moving on what are you doing
Cy a cattle station is like a country
and you have no one to protect
it
we can't let them win we won't feel the
now we going to do a drive with just me
and my two
men that's plenty old enough he is a
child if he doesn't you'll have no
country no
Story the Japanese are coming you must
evacuate
n whatever happens what if it takes
we'll be together I believe
you the only thing you really own is
your
story just trying to live a good
[Music]
one